ya know yeah I'm wearing these glasses
on ironically I don't have my contact
lenses I'm so sorry
let's make all the single [ __ ]
comments about it and ignore the video
thank you very much it's been a pleasure
I'll be good
we are actually making a video even
though it's completely relevant Yahoo
Answers you can ask anything in Yahoo
Answers some random person might answer
it well I thought I'll find the
PewDiePie questions and I'll answer in
I was just wondering and I'm a huge fan
like what started him being hated I
don't get it really like my friend at
school say he's gay stupid and hit these
offensive things that got me so angry I
punched him in the face XD Jesus crying
but if you could tell me in the least
insulting way to him I'll tell you why
oh boy where do I even begin there are
so many reasons
number one it started off getting really
popular way too fast never get never get
got way too many young fans watching me
from the beginning
most of my comedy was based up screaming
yelling yelling of offensive slurs and
as soon as people started hating on me I
went and acted like the biggest [ __ ]
overly defensive idiot about it and then
it just kind of took off my videos are
pretty cringy not really that funny um
just some young kid being way more
popular than he should be
I open my eyes a try
see but I'm blinded by the way
let's see what the best answer is
PewDiePie is awesome and I love him but
sometimes it doesn't think before they
said stuff they can be racist or
offensive to some also people think uh I
think a lot before I say stuff it's
always the question is do we leave the
joke in or do we edit it out I really
appreciate offensive jokes but a lot of
people don't and it's it's just how you
do it sometimes you can pull it off
sometimes you can't and people people
are way too sensitive
all the people think is screaming is
annoying in fact that he fails to be
funny yeah who is better pudy pie or
tobyGames oh yeah back in the day people
would compare me to Toby Turner a lot
because we both played happy wills but
I've always clearly been better
that's right Toby do you watch PewDiePie
yes brofist
hell no Peter pie is a huge massive
[ __ ] all he cares about is
subscribers
[ __ ] hell do people really have time
to write this [ __ ] P 5 channel has just
sub 4 sub 4 sub 4 stuff here's here's
about subscribers stupid kids kids are
so dumb who is the worse youtuber on
YouTube best answer PewDiePie
oh man come on Internet Wendy when are
you gonna cut me some slack
what did I do to you come on man come on
come on who is this person come on Dex
come on Dex likes to help accounting
problems or what's a good manga let's
let's judge you here all right let's see
here what are some good anime slash
manga all right let's see what your
recommended Oh
so you recommend sword art online code
guess all mainstream animate alert
mainstream anime nerd alert right this
has been fun wow this is growing great
guys this is going really good I really
feel confident about this this video
Peter Piper's markiplier who do you
think is better
I think PewDiePie is better because he's
more funnier than markiplier but
markiplier is awesome too
that's right mark what you gonna do when
you're gonna cry
three pies in the top most handsome men
really there must be something wrong
with it
oh hey Norman Reedus you got [ __ ] by
booty pop [ __ ] oh where does peopIe
live they actually [ __ ] added my old
address in Italy
nice nice invasion of privacy
yeah I'm sure you'd like that it
happened to you huh that'd be [ __ ]
great why is peopie the number one
youtuber when he just pulls himself
playing games because that's what you
think people will take something they
will make it into the smallest thing and
then be like why I don't understand
maybe if you looked a little deeper than
that if you think I just post videos on
myself playing games then you're a
[ __ ] idiot but don't worry about it
still love you please subscribe alright
this has been Yahoo Answers PewDiePie
edition thank you so much for watching
if you learned something nearly but like
you can leave it like anyway because
that way I get more likes subscribe if
you're not a bro already and I will see
you tomorrow with a new video as every
[ __ ] single day how about that
alright thank you both so much for
watching and as always stay awesome
brush from the rocky shores of Hawaii
really really this would kill me for
years I would have to go to therapy are
you serious from the rocky shores to
Hawaii to the beaches of Hawaii are you
serious how are you not destroyed